um i've been recording for a while
actually that's all right that's
it the pre-show generally not a problem
that's the goals right there alan
partridge banter
but it's only your perspective because
no one else is recording so it's you
talking about alan partridge
genuinely like i feel like this might be
the next good place for austin this
might be the next rabbit hole for him to
go down it's just like the history of
alan partridge this 20 year old
uh comedy character that's true i'm
still are you familiar with alan
partridge
absolutely did you did you watch the
trip either the first or the second i
really want to but i have because those
are fun yeah yeah
my god they're they're
he's brilliant it's coogan yeah he's
crazy and it's it's
this wonderful self-deprecating but even
the second one the second one is even
more like poignant and um
surprisingly good ellen partridge uh
i mean i loved him and you know oh uh
bride and rob ryden
yeah oh really
i have a photo of me and rob bryden when
i was like 50 and
i was if i had it to hand i would send
it to you right now pull it off the
bookshelf i'm very better to say it's
probably on the bookshelf
that's just did you um troy did you ever
see philomena
with coogan um and judy dench
dame judy tinch please the dame judi
dench she
she plays a woman who late in life
reveals
she had a kid that was taken away by
like nuns or something when she was a
teenager she had
she had a marriage and then she
basically or she had a child
as a kid and then never told anyone for
like 70 years
and then finally this is chinatown and
then finally uh reveals it and he plays
this journalist who's basically
trying to help her track down whatever
happened to this kid
and when did this come out it's so good
it's i really liked it
um it's got some really affecting things
in it and it's it's definitely a drama
but there's this one great moment that
sold me on it
um where they're in you know she plays
this woman who you know these nuns
um really really basically screwed up
her
life by taking away her kid and she
but she remains very religiously devout
and there's this great scene that was in
like i think actually
i think steve coogan went on like the
daily show or something
uh to promote it and they showed this
clip and that sold me on the film where
you see the two of them in the car
together and and um
she goes do you believe in god and he
goes well i mean it's just gonna have to
be the i guess the dependent
of how you define god and i mean
different people that believe different
things at different times and then it
gives this long meandering like
waffling and then ends with kind of this
unsatisfactory like so i guess it just
depends uh
how about you most religious debates
often do
oh yeah and after going through this
whole song and dance how about you and
she's just
yes based on the description of that
i would not have guessed it were a
comedy no it's not at all
okay but i could see it being in the
same way that the trip
especially the second one my favorite
scene of course that everyone was
quoting from and
what got me hit to the movie was the in
the trip was uh
them sitting there doing their michael
caine i've seen that too i've seen that
particularly
but the reason that i i'd asked if you
were familiar with aaron park
allen of partridge troy was because like
that's one of those things that i
would always wonder if i were to show it
to an american would they find it funny
and i have that struggle with like a lot
of australian stuff where i'm like
i um summer high thai
was like i feel like you really have to
understand
australian culture i was reading
something today and it's like it's not
about
unders uh translating the word it's
about translating the culture
and in order to fully understand it you
really have to translate the culture and
i
i feel like there was i grew up watching
like my parents were weird
and so we watched a lot of like the
foundational bbc things like faulty
towers
and are you being served and um
i watched when people started talking
about doctor huh
life of pride you know the classics
and my parents would be like you know
when people started getting hip to dr
who i was like
that's like the cheesiest sci-fi show
ever it's like one thing up from lost in
space
and i didn't realize what they had done
with dr who until
much much much later um so i mean like i
i grew up watching this stuff so i kind
of have a foundational knowledge or tur
you know like a
i can understand ad hoc the culture that
is
you know british humor but do you know
the muffin man
who lives on dreary lane
[Laughter]
do you know erwin allen the master of
disaster
was behind the original lost in space
do you know who he hired to score that
show
the original um i'm going to say
knowing you it was probably leonard
bernstein no his one and only
film credit is on the waterfront he did
not he looked down on film scoring he he
was not a fan
really yeah after doing on the
waterfront he goes i'm never doing that
again
he was also he was also resentful
well he was also resentful of the fact
that uh west side story won
like 10 oscars but not for its music
uh uh it was dominated
um okay then it's gonna be um
uh not john williams it's gonna be
[Laughter]
yep a young he was still johnny williams
at the time
and johnny williams hit his band
i feel like you need to write the
biography of john williams
i could my bookshelf and then
try uh the audiobook version
brilliant it makes me realize i don't
think that any i don't
know no one's ever done the biography
written like a proper kind of
authoritative
i also think that he's gonna be like
john williams is gonna be like uh
methuselah he's just going to live to be
or he could be like enoch and he's just
going to disappear to vapor he's never
really going to die he's just going to
like
descend into the mist yeah he'll just
ascend speaking of
style i mean he's eddie van halen
i didn't realize he had had cancer uh
for 20 years
i knew about the hip and i knew that he
had cancer but
again just kind of 20 years sounds like
the cancer had him
yeah we talked about this and someone uh
wolf said he had a long and arduous
battle with cancer and i was like
what an interesting way to phrase that i
just
i we we just ended up jumping on talking
about it yesterday and
and like he's an icon it's it's it's an
icon
you're no longer a person you're an
institution like you're
in the you know 2020 terms you're a meme
at this point yeah
when you become when you become a
synonym for a thing like
if you're with a band and you're like
let's just van halen this
yeah what i mean like that that would
actually mean something to a guitarist
in a band in the same way that like
composer to composer you can say
you know let's let's philip glass this
or something and it's like there's
certain people that just become
a thing yeah oh you can't doubt that one
you can't
just say like i would i thought you were
gonna go a little bit more like
every man and be like beethoven or
mozart or whatever no but that's the
thing i think it's actually more obvious
what i mean
if it's philip glass for what it's worth
i chose carefully
i do i i you always do but
actually yeah i um there's a um there's
a composer
uh sort of acquaintance and a friend i'm
so presumptuous to call him a friend but
a composer acquaintance that i
like mark shaman who's a legend he's
written a lot of broadway stuff and
he he he worked with trey trent parker
and matt stone for a while and
anyway he he's just had the most amazing
life working with all these different
people and icons and
and um he wrote a little tribute to van
halen when he said he was
he was helping in 1987 i'm reading this
from his instagram because i just
thought this was so cool where he said
i always loved this about people like
this i didn't know this about van halen
where he said in 87
he was helping with the band on snl when
van halen's wife valerie bertinelli was
hosting
i was the music guy writing staff that
year um
and wednesday we did a run read through
of the submitted sketches and i was at
the piano
and there was a sketch that called for
the classic keyboard part of jump to be
played and so i played it van halen
looked at me
and he had just this huge giant lit up
smile like a kid on christmas morning he
seemed
still even at that point excited by all
of this
and i just love whenever you come across
stories of someone who's like
like fully a legend and then when you
hear those behind the scenes moments and
they're just like
wow about what's going on and they're
not sort of above it or
or yeah uh just they're enjoying it
they're living it right and the way that
they described it too the grinning
guitarist
i was like yeah man that's why he and
david lee roth were so good as they were
just like having their kids having the
time of their life
i remember something similar to that
seeing um right now and it's just
tons of photos of him even in his older
age just smiling it's really cool
yeah i saw roger waters at the bowl
um that was my first concert at the bowl
actually it was this fever dream of
of circumstance but um
i remember looking at i had met roger
waters the night before
just by happenstance um and he was kind
and gracious
and but watching him on stage and him
looking out of the audience
as people are singing you know in mass
his lyrics and his music back to him
and he looked like he was just shocked
that anyone was in the audience
and it's the same thing you're talking
about us and you're like i can't believe
you guys know this song you're like it's
a seminal record like everybody knows
this
every if you don't know if you even
heard the two words pink and floyd
you equate them with dark side of the
moon at least the wall
yeah so it's just like people like that
that uh their contribution to
art and contribution to the world is so
indelible i have just such an admiration
for
and and especially when they maintain
their humanity
and their humility throughout that
process i just i i really that's what i
asp i
i it's not that i just aspire to
accomplish great things like they do
i i want to accomplish it the way that
they did and
with the integrity the attitude the
attitude yeah
yeah yeah it's a it's a tremendous loss
um
but you know i don't think it's the
first time i've said it on this podcast
this year but cancer's a real piece of
[ __ ]
uh we're not [ __ ] off cancer we would
like it to [ __ ] off
that would be super nice um and
yeah sort of to your point that trey i
wanted to bring up the billy eilish
thing
uh she was pretty profusely made fun of
for not knowing who
van halen are with some people saying
like there's no excuse for young people
um
it wasn't that a while ago wasn't that
like a controversy like
a year or two ago yeah i remember 20
years ago
that was it feels like right that
excites me that doesn't insult me that's
amazing that tells us the culture's
moving
not only that but just like come here
put some headphones and this is the oh
you ate one too
have you ever seen it i was gonna say
all of the two brothers i think they're
brothers at least um who just
experienced music for the first time
yes i don't know if we've spoken about
it before but like it's it's so fun to
watch like
was it phil collins like this it was it
was in the air tonight they were like
that song's about his divorce it's just
like this dirty gritty rock song
that song inspired more drummers like
that
that song alone is what made me pick up
two drumsticks
and beat the [ __ ] out of pillows just
waiting i couldn't play anything else
but it went again
that's what made me want to play the
drums yeah yeah all kinds of awesome
um so that's that um that thing you're
describing of like the weird
the weird cultural elitism of needing to
you know i you you need to know all the
things i know
lest i not take you seriously um
i think is missing what i mean you just
you just both
or all of you uh kind of nailed it with
that
the joy of discovering those things to
me if i had one superpower
it would be to give myself amnesia to go
back and like hear certain things for
the first time or watch certain movies
again or play certain games or read
certain books
for the first time again oh yeah like
that to me would
that would be if i could snap my fingers
and just forget
star wars uh uh and just which one
episode yeah phantom menace
i just need it again um yeah
it it to me it's it's i i the best the
best professor i ever had
was um my
college music history professor and the
whole this was one where
you know hundreds of students had to
take this class of all music major
types you know composer all the
performance majors and
singers and blah blah and uh the whole
point of his class was to like make sure
that everybody leaves this program kind
of
on equal footing in terms of their
knowledge of the basics of the
of the historical kind of classical
tradition
uh at least the at least the the western
and the us
specifically and it was but it's a lot
of materials taught over four semesters
it was a two
two year and we would always every you
know every so often we'd come across
like another one of those
war horse like like you know beethoven's
fifth like things that just it's hard to
imagine
someone could audition to get into a
university
music program and not have ever heard
this piece but the whole point was to
say let's not presume anything
so we're just gonna make we're gonna
cover everything that sort of
really lays the foundation of this art
form and so every now and again you know
a beethoven's fifth a mozart's requiem
uh a
you know a uh the planets right of
spring
these pieces would come up in between
you know more obscure ones but he would
always ask the class
okay don't be shy who here today we're
gonna talk about
beethoven's fifth who here has never
heard this piece
and you know it's a lecture hall of 500
students most of whom are 18 and 19. so
at first it's like
you wouldn't dream of raising your hand
my hand up
yeah he in that room he he he made it
clear like
i'm not judging you i'm just curious
yeah exactly it can't feel that way not
conductive sticks man they're big and
heavy like
this was this was his genius though
because he really was good at
kind of taking the temperature down and
being like it's all good
you know and he had taught at nyu since
1968 you know alan menken had been his
student and so he goes
uh he goes um uh
raise your hand so like out of 400 kids
like
maybe 20 on on a on a piece as seminal
as beethoven's fifth for example
and there's like 20 and of course the
whole class is looking around and see
whose hands are these
and he would look at those 20 and he'd
go i
envy the experience you're about to have
and then he'd push play
and it was just like everybody kind of
vicariously got to listen
through their fresh perspective and it
was like holy [ __ ] i've heard this
before
but i kind of haven't until this moment
and it was just
it this guy just effused a love
of this material not to mention that you
know
multiple decades of teaching the same
thing and he seemed just as excited to
share it
that day as probably since 1968 and
anyway i just thought it was amazing
we've been doing this like movie
screening things on saturdays where
every movie is chosen because somehow
organically we'll talk about it's like
well you know it's like
it's like in shawshank redemption
someone goes i've never seen that movie
i haven't seen that what
huh i haven't seen it oh my god you so
mike you have right
oh yeah okay okay 50 times
all right brag about it
like exactly kind of mocking myself
because i think what's interesting with
shawshank is
and i don't know troy you might disagree
with me but like it's kind of an
it's the best seven out of ten movie
ever made like it's
not i think on a lot of levels it's not
a great i don't think this one's the
classics
it's actually if you look at the history
of it like it did really badly in the
cinema and just
blew up because of home video because
it's just one of those movies that
people go back to
it is one of those movies that you can't
just watch once you're going to watch 50
times in your life
um that was why i laughed it was not a
smug arrogance that i'd seen a movie
that was
interesting i i i can totally understand
it because i see what you're saying it's
like
it it performs and it does what it does
very well
um it's it's actually a wonderful
yeah i just looked up the box office uh
and and
did do well worldwide gross was 28
million against a 20
25 million dollar budget whoa i thought
it was
because it it was also nominated for it
was massively successful
it's a very precious position it was it
and it was it was
on the tail end of vhs so it did really
well on vhs and then when dvd came in
it's like
i've got to have a dvd of shawshank of
course i have it grand theft auto
exactly you know you gotta get it on all
your platforms across that generation
absolutely yeah
i uh recently it's important it's fun
the different the
things that i enjoy about that is is dip
people's different takeaways like
someone said about shawshank it's like
it's the only
um it's it's a rarity because it's a
wonderful movie about a platonic
relationship between two men
that is not a comedy
it's like we'll do wedding crashers and
we'll do you know all in
all these movies that you know two bros
but as far as like
two men that are just friends that
genuinely do everything they do out of
love for each other i was like
i've never looked at shawshank that way
i've i've viewed it as a man escaping
prison
i've viewed it as
i was going to say if you asked me what
i thought it would be about i would be
like
prison film maybe somebody dies in
prison
and it's sad i think maybe but that's
just
it's it to me it's just so great it's
one of those movies that kind of has
everything
it does right like it's it's
heartwarming it's got drama
it's got um it also has one of the
single
most pervasively imitated scores um
yeah tom thomas thomas newman right see
that was that was the score
that that was the uh that was the one
that kind of made him go
from you know known
to yeah yeah well yeah to some johnny
williams and tommy newman
he um it's awesome he he just that score
there's one scene in particular there's
a
there's this one particular cue that's
just this very atmospheric piano that
was in every temp track and every
composer still to this day
at some point or another is asked to
copy this cue
uh because it's like it's so unobtrusive
you can put it against any dialogue and
anything
and it just adds something magical and
he he created a genre of music that
that uh he himself has then had to fight
to escape
because he's been asked to do it so many
times uh but he's just he's a real
distinct talent and that
that score was the one it was that one
and then a couple years later american
beauty
he just he did these pair of scores that
are just like
yeah it's just ping it's like what dave
adventure called the
torn movie poster era the torn movie
poster
basic instinct fatal attraction uh
he was like there was one person at like
universal whatever it was like that
created this genre of
torn movie posters i was like holy [ __ ]
that's right
that's so funny uh
mike congratulations on a launch well
made
yeah your hair looks tamer hi everyone
welcome
that's smell from pulling all right yes
i'm alana this is my closet troy
uh we might have a shorter episode today
it's been uh it's been a real week
and i know troy has to run at some point
but mike
you released a video game we did
successfully
yeah it's kind of a hit um which is
which has led to lots of fun chats today
um i know i've been distracted apologies
for my typing while we're talking is
incredibly rude
um yeah it's going very well i think
it's no that's cool but i'm british i
meant to assume
that's right yes constantly i appreciate
your apology
you being on this podcast is a charity
act on our part basically
it's it's yes consequently this is the
success of mike bithell's game and this
is his last episode
i've got what i needed out of this
podcast thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen mr ramy ismail
[Laughter]
i mean he's got lots of time on his
hands at the moment he's worth checking
out he's chilling out worth highlighting
before you dive in though as
i was reminded by uh alana's um
uh uh snippet of my right hand
on instagram it was exactly one year ago
almost like yesterday i think
that we did our new york comic-con panel
yes birthed this very thing yeah
it was it was the fifth it was saturday
the fifth was can you believe
that that was a year ago no
it feels like a different lifetime it
really really does two months ago to me
feels like a different lifetime
yeah i'm just thinking about that
recently about the perception of time
and like just how much i've only seen my
own face
it's just in fairness you live in a
house of mirrors so that
take down the story yeah
it's true in any case yeah i don't mean
to take us off of uh
mike's uh debrief that's cool well
that's my that's my
that's my next job is in well this all
by the time this goes out it'll be out
there but in 25 minutes i have to
remember to hit the tweet button because
we're
announcing uh the tweet release of john
wick hex
exciting everything wait wait wait what
yeah right yeah that game did alright as
well so that's going to
sw so it's out on ps4 and epic store
right now but we're doing steam
switch xbox and we're putting in boxes
and yeah
cool it's coming out i don't know 25
minutes on my head but yeah
in 25 minutes like basically i've got
the tweet ready to go i have to hit
enter
on that tweet so i have to just keep an
eye once you're on
the points
like you could schedule them but that
always goes wrong for me i always end up
saying them too early and i get in
trouble so i
just i just picture you with like this
cartoon dynamite plunger that activates
your twitter
just a switch like eddie van halen
and uh um who else were we talking about
evan halen and
roger waters um do you
is there something that surprised you
about do you kind of feel like i can't
believe that people
like this game i can't believe that
people are playing this game or did you
kind of know going in it's like if
people will just play this they'll love
it
with solitaire yeah i think well the
play testing was the best we've ever had
like definitely there were a lot of very
early signs that like the game was good
the first round of play testing we had a
terrible tutorial initially i mean every
tutorial always sucks
when you first start like it's you
you're it's always a couple of play
tests before your tutorial gets good or
at least
shape people why don't you get this yeah
yeah but like other than that we were
definitely getting from like day one
really good play test we fixed the
tutorial we knew that was solved
we knew it was good we we we weren't
sure
because it's just our games are always
completely different from each other so
we just didn't know if there was an
audience there turns out a lot of people
played solitaire as kids
and kind of like the idea of a more
advanced grown-up solitaire
so with greg miller it's not just with
greg miller and i love that because the
reaction to that's been excellent
because a lot of people were a little
sniffy and like greg's not an actor and
all this stuff
and actually then people play and they
go oh he's fun like he's doing he's
doing a good job here so yeah he's being
the guy in the chair so i'm i'm happy
with that yeah no it was
i'll come for you in the night greg i'll
cover yeah you're gonna it's gonna be i
want you i want i'm gonna make sure we
nominate him for the baftas just
like it's a great so i'm not surprised
greg miller for everybody for
yeah it's greg miller obviously it's
gregor villa it's the performance of the
year
um but no it's been so it wasn't it was
it was we knew we had a good game
what's been really fun has been watching
just that
level of engagement with it and also
just
yeah it's like it's outselling
everything we've ever done before so
it's kind of interesting to watch that
curve as well
and we're learning a lot and we're
honestly at that point there's a certain
point and
this might seem a bit abstract but
essentially there's a point once as a
developer you're aware that your game is
going to make enough money to like pay
your staff which is
where we're at like it's doing it's
doing fine it's on course to do all that
which is the important thing
at that point it almost becomes abstract
that you're like oh these numbers are
really interesting i wonder what's
causing that
and all there's a spike like you you it
becomes it stops being real money you
stop looking at it like
like your bank account because i mean
you'd go mad if that was actually how
you looked at sales data
so it's actually now it's just mainly me
and my business partner alexander just
nerding out
like ooh ooh that the the you know the
chinese players are coming in
at this time of day and that's
interesting and like you know is that
because we made a specific logo for that
version of the game in that
in that country yeah second sorry i love
donna like that's like a thing that is
a big part of my job like why are people
like i've had this conversation with
this show where it's like we're not
trying to make money but i'm like yes
but
in my my the way that i my producer
brain works is i still want
metrics of success to track and why have
they contract that way i find it really
fun
is that something like honestly it's a
lot of the same stuff so
you can you could replicate that or do
you feel that that
that is only indicative of that game
like or do you do you take that
information and go okay so for the next
game we know that we need to this was
successful therefore we need to
replicate
this thing in the next game or do you
think it's only holy to that game
there's lessons there for sure we all i
think the big thing for me with
every game is i always go into every
game being like
this is a hit-driven business it makes
the numbers won't make any sense it's
all like
it's all luck and challenge and who
knows what the world's gonna want right
now and
blah blah i go in with that attitude on
every single game and about this point
with every game so we're just over 24
hours now
it's like oh yeah we're just doing that
game times
whatever like we're just you know you
you go oh
everything is really predictable the
sales curve you do so basically like
when you launch your game on steam
uh and you you know a little bit later
you can actually see that like hour by
hour so those
that data is so much fun to look at as
alana says
that curve always looks exactly the same
all you're basically doing is like
resizing it in why
so you know how successful the game is
yeah you so those are those data points
you like you're like there's no way that
curve is going to end up being smooth
and proper like we'd expect and then
every single time it always is and it's
like
so your constants grow and then you just
add in new variables
yeah so yeah exactly so there are
certain expectations you can have as a
developer
and there are certain truism some of
them are more true than
others like there's definitely like
there's as we said last time
on the episode there's like there's
certain numbers that you can predict
with wish listing for example
and those numbers always work out
working exactly as you expect them to
and then other things always track
exactly as you say the there's there's
some there's some stats that are varied
by
multiples so um there is a certain i
don't want to go into specific side but
there are certain numbers that
developers know of like
oh if you do x amount of units in your
first day then you can expect this many
units in your first week this in the
first month this in your first year
there are the
long game or is it just that no
at my scale no because bluntly there are
always going to be more people who've
never [ __ ] heard of me like that's
like from a mathematical point i'm sure
that comes into it
[Laughter]
the company
i think my favorite part of that was the
the tiny little bit of
caramel salt sea salt on top of troy
pointing in the wrong direction again to
be like who's this guy
because he's he's never here to me hey
buddy high five me i have a question for
you alana
um did it drive you or to this day does
it still
drive you crazy um whenever you watch
uh an episode of star trek the next
generation they call them data
no that's actually um preferable
property because
then it's a name yeah so data
stupidest question ever do you remember
what are you thinking of me
do you remember that classic line though
with the doctor doctor what's what was
her name that that temporarily replaced
crusher
polonsky pulaski pulaski hi
where uh shut up she uh she goes data
come over here or something like that
and he goes it's data and she goes data
data what's the difference
yeah i know you haven't been on this
show but one is my name what the other
is not
what about what about what's her name
that the the other doctor who came on
and um she she was the original
voice on the computer you know that
right like module barrett's
wife was yeah was the original voice or
she she was
that doctor but um the pulaski
was the voice of the computer isn't that
right no plus
you're talking about star trek so star
trek next gen
uh the actress who played beverly
crusher who is mcfadden
gates mcfadden that's right she got into
like a disagreement with the producers
so for one season they removed uh
and replaced her with dr pulaski who was
like this grumpy old
basically intentionally like dr mccoy
style vibes right they were going for
total she was of course because cv she
was played by like a 40 year old woman
but they play they made out that she was
this old
cranky doctor um and then that kind of
didn't work and crusher came back
in the first series yes the the actress
uh magill barrett
who was married to gene roddenberry
plays the ship's computer
lewis anna troy who's oh my god my brain
is so full of this nonsense
troy is the computer she's the computer
so she's magical
and in the first season season she plays
a doctor who i'm forgetting the name of
but that's who you're talking about troy
that's what i'm talking about original
series yeah but apparently and did you
know this that
um gates mcfadden came on
and everyone called hi cheryl and that
was her name and then she decided
like season two she goes i want you to
call me gates and they're like
really what because she's a dancer right
that was her background she yeah
she was a choreographer choreographer
according to wikipedia
but i i talked to somebody who was on
the show and they were like it was the
weirdest thing it's all of a sudden we
have to call like if you just showed up
one day and you're like
i want you to call me fellmore and be
like
your name is mike is like my name is
fellmore like i'm googling because i'm
pretty sure gates mcfadden like
choreographed a massive movie franchise
or massive movie musical
um that we're all forgetting she's like
a really accomplished choreographer as
well
aside from patrick stewart i've met
everybody on the deck of the enterprise
that's done
so jealousy flex how did you collect
them all
um i got one of those little balls yeah
i just show up to their house
and just i just need to meet you uh
that's the beauty of like this one of
the things i miss about cons
is like being um backstage levar burton
was the last one
honestly oddly enough i had a great time
um getting down with uh well
going up to levara burton was oddly um
emotional for me because i was like dude
the the
impact that you've had has been like
crazy like on a generation not only
he's got the double whammy gates
mcfadden's well you have to include
roots also
labyrinth no way the triple whammy for
him was not only you know
reading rainbow and was like you taught
me the importance of reading
but also being brainless huh
the importance of rainbows don't worry
about it i love how alana you're just
permanently out of focus
yeah that's fine i'm with it but your
background is tart you know
uh tax chart um my my favorite one
though
was um getting drunk with um
uh marina siertas
i think i've heard this story yeah dfw
airport and
um turning her onto the fact that at
that time
there was a uh admirals club at dfw that
you could smoke in and she was like i'm
to go outside and
i'm off for smoke i was like you know
you can smoke at the admirals club and
she's like i don't have a membership
she's like i'm only a counselor so it's
like come with me
so i got she got to be in there as my
guest
and he sat down and lit up and i had a
couple cocktails did you only ask her
questions about playing
uh liara his mother in uh mass effect
one
uh i talked to her about uh gargoyles
for damn sure
no what an opportunity missed
[Laughter]
she's been she's uh you could have
always said hd remake
i didn't know she was vanessa i had no
idea yeah
it's yeah it's that's why i was when i
first played that i was like
i was like that's that's deanna troy
uh she is she's one of the coolest
people and she's just
cockney tottenham hotspur support sir
and she just goes like this and she's so
great she's
i really really uh my dream i
jonathan frakes has the distinction of
directing a movie that jerry scored
and i've always wanted to hang with him
and get a sense of
like that experience he's an impressive
fella as well like he doesn't get enough
credit for like he walked into a show
was like basically like the hot
commander right and he
left that show was like a director who
could help movies who
he basically kind of went up to the
bosses and basically demanded the
opportunity to like
and then set in motion this thing where
star trek became a school for directors
basically like
if you look at like several of like the
act so like the actors if you look at
voyager in particular
most of the casts of that show are now
just directing every tv show you watch
it started crazy and that started a
trend right specifically on upn
where you got to
it's it's a common thing now for actors
on a show to direct that episode
and that started with that and he he
didn't make any money
any money until he started directing oh
nice well now you've done it yeah i've
made it i think you look i don't know i
think
the breaks wouldn't stand for this yes
now you're uh you're redacted for being
i know i'm being scented for some reason
i don't know what i've done exactly
but geez just seeing you
yeah that's awesome i need uh i need you
to get your royal flush though and get
sir stew in there i gotta get sir stew
yeah everybody else um
yeah i'd love to meet him one day uh
absolutely same absolutely same
uh oh you do we should have ourselves
yeah let's let's make that happen and
he'll be and he'll be beautiful
patrick the invite is there if you if
you want to join us
mike you're british sort me out stop
being out for me
you know him yeah you must be neighbors
or something
i have been trying to like worm my way
to accessing sir patrick stewart for
years and i've failed but if i ever
succeed
as a proper englishman in another role
in whatever it is if i have a game
you know patrick stewart had this role
originally and uh
yeah he took me down so now so now and
and then also jonathan frakes oh and by
the way
there was a crewman number five in an
episode of season three
he said
until then i'm gonna go into my next job
that's not working for mike bithell
ever again it's a terrible idea but for
again one and done right
yeah i gotta do are you gonna are you
planning are you planning your uh
of dlc now featuring secret
new suits of cards and super powers we
are having all the conversations because
we when something like this happens you
have to ios
like genuinely we're talking everything
right now i don't i don't know it's all
about being evasive i genuinely don't
know like it's just
it's one of those things it's a great
problem to have but we have no idea what
to do because we genuinely thought this
thing would
be a you know nice mild you know does
its job makes his money back but
it seems it's more than that so we have
to work out how to do that properly
it's very it's very i was able to play
it for about an hour
uh and i did before you got disgusted
yeah exactly it would be fast
and uh i made it about one i just stared
at a wall for three hours because i
figured it was better
this is enough thank you the sheer
the sheer commitment to that like tony
scott
sort of over the top vibe thank you for
the tony scott that is 100
was going for and you're the first
person to say i appreciate that
yeah it's 100 percent i've seen a movie
or two in my time
it's not it really it really is just so
see you later troy
you've troy's been going out oh no i was
saying two minutes but i do need to run
i was like he's seen two minutes two
movies two minutes
i don't know anymore no
it's it's just it's fun how how
relentlessly committed
what say goodbye austin you're kicking
me out
no i'm saying say goodbye austin
bye everybody see you later
i i don't even know my brain just got
completely
like men in blacked by that uh but
um no yeah i i i cheers to you
for uh a successful just complete and
total straight-faced commitment to that
aesthetic where it
it doesn't like announce it as kind of a
cutesy thing and then
step back and be like okay you know
let's not forget that it is in fact
solitaire it's just like nope we're just
gonna we're just gonna keep that
the the heat turned on at full power the
this whole time and it's it's
it's it's to me well john everest is
doing a lot of the work with that like
in terms of like he he definitely is
scoring it like it's a much more
action-packed game than someone
yeah oh undoubtedly and i was i was
analyzing the way in which the kind of
progress
through i was my my theory is that
the number of cards placed in the center
is the primary metric
driving your music system your theory
has weight to it yes uh yeah i think you
might be right
maybe educated you maybe worked that out
yeah
um it's it's hip-hop it's just the
hitman thing of just rising the
intensity
as yet yeah yep no it's it's working
it's working great and
and cheers to john as well in particular
for the the
the main title especially is like i was
like i can't remember the last time i've
actually reached to turn down the volume
on something before because it was just
so like
and i was i was i was like you know
what's funny is i think people are not
going to realize that this is also a
very funny game
uh like it's like just for the because
it's just
so because you know the tony scott thing
in this context is is quite hilarious uh
but uh yeah anyway i i look forward to
hours
two three and how long is the campaign
in general i think i made it i think i'm
like on mission
there's well the the non so the rule of
game development is you always have to
pretend your game is short and it is
because there'll be someone who gets
through it faster than whatever number
you say
so the real is like it's about four
hours but
i say two hours because
so i appreciate that most go it's about
20 which means
it's about probably not 10 minutes yeah
no
it's usually the other way for us we
actually we tend to roll down because we
just know people will
because most people round up yeah the
audience the audience definitely like
halves any number you tell them so we
tend to say
even smaller so that they're surprised
by how much of it there is
this is why i love the site how long to
beat.com
i know it might it's the best because i
looked on that actually that's probably
got some stats
it should do i was gonna ask mike so
you've had a very successful launch
launched yesterday at the time of
recording um
what do you think is the recipe
or the particular ingredients that made
this a successful launch what do you
think it is about this game
do you think covert contributed is it
the fact that solid tests are
recognizable
is it just the style was very appealing
to people like what do you think did it
so i think definitely we're in a time
where everyone's just like
aching for content right like i don't
know about you guys but like if i see a
new movie i'm half interested in show up
on like netflix i'm excited because like
something new right so i think there is
a bit of that i think there's
the times we are living in but no i
think it's combination of things it's
definitely the art and aesthetic of it
it's just people love the
the artwork uh gendered on the uh on the
characters it's fantastic i think we did
a good job with the ui
and the graphic design and all that
stuff so it looks it looks a lot more
expensive than it is basically
it's also a very funny quality vibe to
that end i i enjoy that one of the kind
of unlockables is the
color scheme like yeah that turns that's
massive people loving that it's so funny
like i i put a lot of thought into that
or i'm like do i
do i really want to keep this color
because that's most of the content right
like that's
yeah it's but that came out that was
just because i loved that feature in the
original deus ex and just
no one ever does it because it's
actually real right i forgot about that
yeah you're right yeah
it's really it's really annoying
probably the most complicated bear
coding in the whole game is making those
color schemes work
yeah it's just pain absolute pain in the
ass but once i like like once i'd seen
how cool it was i had to then actually
make it work um but it's just funny that
you make it a reward for the player it's
not like a thing you go into the menu
and you go hunting like for graphics
options or changing the gamma or
whatever it it's literally like
congrats you have the new color scheme
great you've got new color scheme
but then that makes people value it more
which is really interesting and we
actually have to like in our messaging
on steam make it clear that like
this is not there are no micro
transactions like this isn't us like
upselling you stuff because
yeah we thought people would might worry
that that was like what that was the um
but
i think the genius of the color scheme
thing is um is an idea from my partner
alexander
who he put in this uh he suggested this
um
uh this try it button so when you unlock
it you get like a little button that
like
lets you like on that screen try out the
thing you just unlocked which wasn't
there like it was just you have to
literally go to settings each time
to change it and just by doing that
right that's why it works it feels the
thing
i've watched people stream the game and
they've spent like five minutes like
doing what you're saying i'm like
humming and ironing about do i prefer
this color palette to the one i've got
and all this stuff
so that's cool um and then i think uh
definitely
like uh it definitely did well on social
media there were definitely a lot of um
like people with high follow accounts
kind of talking about it and stuff like
that that's that's definitely helped to
kind of fuel the fire a little bit
um for the record there are no stats yet
on how long to beat dot com
oh no the game has a page basically the
game has a page but it just says there's
nothing it'll take a little while to
populate yeah
it's not enough but it's um but yeah no
it just it just seems to have connected
i think yeah i think the other thing
that's really good for us
and and it's a weird thing because
players definitely want innovation they
want stuff that's original
which is cool and that's something we do
but i think also what
players often want as well is a
consistency of
not um not necessarily of the games
you're making but of of the way you're
behaving i guess
as a developer so what what's helped
with this is because we've made a couple
of these short games before
people know what this is they so there's
that kind of it's really interesting
looking at user reviews are incredible
and like
uh on steam and everything like
everything the players are loving it
because they know
okay this is not a triple a game i'm
playing this is like uh this is like a
you know a 10 in this case kind of
experience or 10
with the launch discount um so they they
come at it from
in that context and i think because
we've done a couple of these now people
know what to expect and that that frames
it for them better and they
i think as well like a lot of older
players or players who have like
families and stuff like the idea of a
game that is like quite short and like
but like hyper produced for like
something that excites me now
it was a short game i'm like hell yeah
yeah
you're not alone and what's interesting
is i think that that audience overlaps
with an audience who also don't want
something that's super high stress they
and so the idea of like taking solitaire
uh which is a game that's relatively
chill and then figuring out a way to add
like
those production values and to make it
very unjust and drama
basically make it unchill like that that
seems to have worked for a lot of people
so
yeah i don't know but the thing is with
all these things it's always just like
20 different things kind of because i'm
sure there's other things
that people don't like that's putting
them off you know and and those things
probably so it's always this kind of
matrix of like
likes and dislikes the other thing we
did that i think worked really well was
the wish listing that was the thing that
was like
we were really annoying on social media
about wish listing
he
i probably have lost friends over that
wish listing but like it works well i
guess that's the thing that you learned
previously that was necessary going into
this game and
and yeah this is going to be the most um
interview like question i think i've
ever asked anyone on the show but
what would you say is the thing that you
learned making this game
did you have some is there something
that you have learned by making
solitaire conspiracy is there a lesson
so this is hot it's kind of half
something we learned on previous ones
and
one that we definitely learned on this
which is spend all the money on the
screen
like spend every penny and this is what
we did with this one was there's
nothing like everything is
all the budget of the game basically is
spent on stuff the player can see your
experience directly interesting
and that seems to have subtext noted for
music um how do you mean oh and music
oh no sorry i i see you and heard
implicitly
for free implicitly get the cheapest
music possible
it doesn't it all belongs on screen no
but it's true like genuinely like the
only
like and money obviously equals time
essentially in like any kind of creative
thing like this so
effectively this game was made by three
people on the main there were
lots of brilliant talented people who
came in and did like a day or two's work
so like the actors
and the localizers and all this stuff
but in terms of people who were there
the whole time it was me the character
artist who's getting all this amazing
credit for the amazing art she drew
um draw saying drew always sounds really
patronizing all this amazing art she
created lovingly with brilliant talent
um and then of course with the music
but that but the the team was all built
all about production value and all about
getting that on screen and that's
created something that yeah is
and that's something that we can like
you know charge ten dollars for and no
one's really challenging us on the price
because i think
we don't see the value there it's a
fascinating thing like i don't know if
i've ever mentioned this before
um but i intentionally have a setup
whenever i
stream or even make youtube videos that
does not look
professional which is intentional i use
a green screen background i don't care
if it's fuzzy
um my webcam right now is put out of
focus my lighting is not good and and
the reason that i'm okay with that and i
don't want a professional setup is so
that people still are able to recognize
this is not your job so i am fine trade
not a youtuber or a streamer
and i want people to come into that
content and be like this is not
something you're doing professionally
you do it in your spare time and thus i
have the expectation of
i don't get mad at you if you don't do
this every day i won't get mad at you
because it doesn't look this way and
it's
i think worked out very very well is
just that the appearance of this is a
professional youtube channel
would create an entirely different and
um
impossible for me to meet uh demand for
for content
which is just the testament to how the
appearance of something looks can
actually
influence dramatically what an audience
wants from a certain kind of content and
i think that you've done the opposite
way you've made this game
that is effectively solitaire look hyper
flashy which can
you know change the value of the amount
that you charge or whatever else like
that stuff i find super interesting
but it's definitely very important um
getting yeah so what what looking fancy
what
uh is the next is the next uh the next
one gonna be like
mahjong or uh or is next on
the the bethel chopping block like um
what's the um
sudoku are you gonna do like the epic
the epic sudoku take next is that what
is that what's happening
that's the joke but like genuinely like
there is a part of me that's like let's
let's just do the entire windows 311
i actually also really loved your
exchange with rami uh where it was like
for someone who has uh how'd you phrase
it like someone who has politely hated
all of my games
uh yeah ramy has hated everything since
thomas thomas was alone he
like we're good friends but like he
genuinely doesn't like my games like he
liked thomas was alone
and since then he's just been like like
i said politely disliking everything
i've done since
what is this one way he was really into
it so that's exciting why do you think
he
i mean you're very different developers
his games his games have one foot very
squarely in the traditions and almost
the arcade
uh realm of games like if you look at
nuclear throne and ridiculous fishing
and things like that
there's a there's a reel of lamb the uh
uh what was that
uh sort of steve lambie uh what was the
name of the uh the plane um
um lift trousers loofe trousers yeah
like like those games feel very
connected to kind of the history of
gaming whereas yours
uh i think almost this this is probably
the first one that
that has that quality the rest are i
mean the tech space adventures of the
circular games maybe but i think
i think that might be it like i think
for i
i don't know ramy's taster he might he
might disagree with me
i think his taste falls into two
categories
and then non-vividly everything else
good sorry biffle and good
yeah i think i think i don't think i
think with a lot of my games
they emphasize the storytelling and i
think if you're not on board for the way
i tell stories
you're probably not going to like those
games so much right so i think i think i
think
probably that's it to put words in his
mouth and this whereas i think with this
game like it's the game itself is
compelling enough i think even if you
did hate the story in solitaire
conspiracy
you're still getting a compelling
mechanic and it's a an interesting twist
on it hopefully
it seems to be like we've even like
we've we've had you know user reviews
and press reviews where they've
genuinely hated the story but loved the
gameplay
like how did they work and that's
interesting
good good yeah i think we we're mostly
eights we got a couple of ones that did
below that's the metacritics further
below but like um
yeah it was mostly eights which honestly
is where most of our games land
especially the shorts as well because
you know they're not gonna you're we're
never gonna make a short that like
gets a nine that's you make effort to
make sure you like read all of your
reviews i don't read any of them until
usually usually i'll read them like a
couple of months after release
interesting
because at launch it's too emotional at
launch it's just you don't i
can't i can't if someone writes a 10 out
of 10 for me i'll read that but anything
below that i'm too sensitive i'm gonna
get bothered by it
um obviously there is stuff to learn in
reviews so i'll go back and check like
once
once we've been out for a while but yeah
you keep an eye on it of course but
what's what's really
what's really neat is the yeah so i met
a critic
i need to double check that's in the
high 70s
i believe that's going to wobble a bit
though um
and it probably will change by time this
comes out because we're still getting
reviews coming in
um the steam store is like 90 something
positive
uh reviews from the users so we're we're
in a really good place we're in
like touchwood's a relatively standard
place for us which is like
high sevens low eights in terms of press
reviews and like
upwards from 90 with users so that's
weird honestly congrats mike this is uh
this is awesome thank you job well done
that's great
that's really exciting yeah i uh yeah
now we just have to work out what's next
yeah yeah yeah i i still vote man
you've got solitaire [ __ ] you money now
personally you could could you do
bejeweled or
that's probably too licensed you're
probably not allowed to take that one
but
that probably feels like it's owned by
someone probably someone's patented the
match three
specifics there i mean not i mean do you
guys remember when um
king.com uh tried to
sue stoic for trademark
uh violation for the title the banner
saga because they claimed they owned the
word saga yeah
absolutely absurd it was the best thing
they could have ever done for the sales
of the banner
it was it was amazing ubisoft game
immortals phoenix rising which i have
played it's actually pretty fun
it's very breath of the wild esque um
was originally called gods and monsters
and had to change because of monster
energy drink
really yeah i'm like i remember they
announced verified that
monsters apparently that's why the title
has changed so like
an immortal phoenix rising is not a
great title
like i feel like i'm one of the very few
people who's remembering that um
just a such a wild i would i would never
have guessed that that game was
um breath of the wild from that title
too that title makes it sound very like
ultra models phoenix rising to me sounds
like a mobile game
uh i don't know what why that's a thing
in my head that just sounds like it
sounds like three different games
at the same time it sounds like it's a
bundle of oh no you gotta get immortal
you gotta get phoenix and all rising i
love you yeah
well and it's phoenix spelled funny too
yes it is because i always say
yeah f-e-n-y-x yeah it's it's nuts um
i have to run which is unfortunate
because we've got a shorter episode
today but yeah it's been uh just a
whole week um but mike mike congrats
on launching a video game i still have
many more questions that i'm sure we can
get into
i'm gonna ask that you both watch the
thing that just came out this morning
with ps5 did you see that
no check it out though it's like the ps5
um
terrapot i believe they're calling it oh
um
it's a really cool aesthetically
pleasing video
um and it's just it's interesting to
watch
and certainly the most we've seen of the
ps5 because i feel like they've been so
much quieter than
microsoft too like i've got my series x
just right here with my little
seagate terabyte hard drive thing and
controller over there anyway uh yeah
totally check that out we might be able
to talk about that next week but
otherwise thank you for watching
everyone we'll see you all next time
hooray